hi guys my name's camera chambers and
this is cameras never seen this has
reduced it so much space so many people
everyone says it's going to gross me out
and then it's going to freak me out they
can't wait to see my reaction do it and
that movie is the things I honestly
don't know why I waited this long to
watch this film because when somebody
gives me a recommendation of like it's
disgusting in a non like saw kind of
disgusting I mean it's gory but it's a
different kind of gore it's like a scary
gore and like the story is good and it's
just like a well-known scary flick I
don't know why it why haven't I watched
it because that's what I want to consume
in my life every day every moment all
the time so I'm going to tackle it today
I'm very excited so are these people
probably let's get started you haven't
has never seen I really enjoyed that
I think through cameras never seen I've
come to appreciate older movies a lot
more movies that before the series I
would have seen and been like oh it's so
dated and then I just like dismiss it
immediately now I like I'm like oh wow
the practical effects were amazing and
oh my gosh I loved the storylines oh
that's really neat and opened my mind up
a bit I am going to tweet out a couple
people think my predictions are going to
be filming the thing for Tamara's never
seen send out your predictions on what I
saw and specific moments 20 minutes hard
emoji cats
kissing face emoji it starts off on Kurt
Russell who I have to say I'm not a
giant Kurt Russell fan and I don't know
why I think he kind of just doesn't do
it for me as an actor but I have I liked
him in this a lot still had some that
John Wayne desk vibe to him well I don't
know I don't really care about what's
going on here I'm so cool and tough his
character develops in a great way and he
does a really good job great job
Kirti Kurt man my man stand Kurt you
know - he's playing chess wizard back
with video game
were good Gavin and Rob Walker who
always makes fun of Millennials for
having done stuff uh sorry Rob
Skyrim is a millennial game but then you
see this beautiful wolf running from a
helicopter who is shooting at him and
it's mean and I don't enjoy it and he's
got crazy stamina because he's like
consistently out running to public after
in the snow again that dog does cardio
like he wants his dog dead so badly he
doesn't care that his helicopter was
blown up or that his friends that was
driving the house flying the helicopter
Manning the helicopter also died in the
helicopter explosion maybe he's a cat
person but I wrote down no matter what
happens from this point on I'm on that
dog's side hashtag don't kill that dog I
have a framed portrait of him it's not
bad dog but it's a husky that meme husky
you can make this a maze so like let's
go check out where these Norwegian guys
are from their base camp and kind of see
what what's going on and they go it's
all destroyed and they see that somebody
like it killed himself and that effect
allows them because I hate this but he
cut himself and the blood is like frozen
dripping down and it looks amazing then
you see what I finally referred to as
the bird double faced alien fly me I'm
so prepared I a framed husky up an alien
shirt on are they gonna wear daisy
necklace is next what the the dog is the
same what the so I wrote how could you
betray me like this
so they get back from Norwegian camps
and they brought the alien slimy and
they're checking it out and then they
put my favorite character in with the
other Huskies and it starts opening up
its space like it's like a like a flat
it was like a Venus flytrap kind of
thing and then like tentacles start
coming out very like gente hentai and in
May tentacley like just very excitable
lots of tentacles going on lots of blood
spurting at one point he shoots blood
out at one of the other Huskies as like
is that acid no are you cool is that
just disgusting
didn't seem hurt some house keys got
away and then like his true form comes
out a bit and he's still kind of doglike
he's not a beautiful dog star purebred
but he's still a dog and he's my dog
he's no golden doodle but I still love
him so much sciencism
then explain it with a flamethrower
which is awesome like super awesome like
yes keep doing that please and they do
throughout a whole movie they're just
flame throwing stuff and it's so good so
far they're doing everything like right
like horror film right
they all went down there together
they're not separating they have a
flamethrower they like keep it close and
chill the very so like they're doing
things well yes you guys are taking care
of business taking care of business this
next piece of things I wrote her it's an
imitator monster that's just a little
exposition for you and then I hate Kurt
Russell's hack that's just a bit of an
opinion for you you look like a redneck
cowboy in Antarctica then one of the
guys Benning he gets taken over by the
thing and it's so creepy they follow him
out they know it's not bendings anymore
and he gets on his knees in the snow and
he's almost done transforming into
Benny's except for his hands my hands
they were such strong have somebody
sitting there with his hands just
looking up at everyone like and then he
screeches out an alien screech which I'm
a big fan of I think that adds a lot to
aliens if they have a really creepy
alien screech
anyone could be the thing if it
overtakes you and has enough time to
transform without anyone else knowing it
can literally be anyone so Kurt Russell
devises this plan to test it out with
blood though I don't think he should
have tied them up around doing it I know
I mean it makes sense but it's just in a
situation that's so high intensity and
nobody trusts anyone else just hi people
up it just makes me nervous and as so
much stress
another weird part in that though is
they're all cutting their thumbs to get
the blood out it's like you are in a
high-stakes situation
don't you want complete use of your
hands maybe cut your side have you ever
had a paper cut before Kurt Russell
don't you know that when your thumb is
cut it sucks why they needed a girl on
this team I swear to god it's finding
out that anyone can be this thing is
making everyone not trust each other and
so Blair is like freaking out and he is
killing the rest of the dogs so Blair is
in this isolation cave and she's like I
want out I won't hurt anyone I want out
and there's a noose hanging there did he
make that news that's so creepy why is
that there Blair ends up getting taken
over by the aliens and I'm wondering if
he made that while he was still human
and then then it just overtook him and
you couldn't use it cause he's like
planning on using it if you got
overtaken or you didn't know how it
works maybe maybe that's what it is
maybe there's some news hanging your
horse it's fun it's great for the whole
camp so then there's this part where I
don't know this actor's name or the
character's name there's a lot of guys
and he like died but he lived well
jagged eyes and they tried to to like
bring him back
his chest gave him and this bite off the
doctors are and then it comes out and
he's like giant and then his head falls
off in his head is crawling around the
use of its tongue and it's so cool and
the way that they twist the faces for
the thing while it's doing its
transformation is so flippin cool Kurt
Russell is like I'm the hero here blah
blah
so he's like full-on hero mode he kills
bearded dude who was the owner of the
dogs which is another really sad moment
when he finds out Blair told all the
dogs he goes in there and sees them and
it's so sad and I hated I hate that he's
dad so he gets killed by Mac and they
test his blood he wasn't an alien i
wrote both black characters are still
alive
that's something shut up it's a horror
film so the blood test reveals at Palmer
he's like the stoner character he is an
alien and then he starts flipping out
they put him on fire and on fire Palmer
is dope and he looks awesome and I love
it every time someone died I would be
like no my brother Damon was like you
realize most people are going to live
camera right you haven't gotten that yet
okay Kurt Russell puts off what looks
like one stick of dynamite and the
entire base is ruined and it explodes
and blows up even like ones that weren't
even connected to the place they were in
like everything blows up and sit this
one on the side to go
this is it look how elegant what's
impressive oh shit the fingers and Gary
space Blair is like sticking his hand in
aah
that's so brutal Blair those things
comes out in full force and it's like
giant and so that's when Kurt Russell
starts blowing up everything Mac and
child are left and who were kind of like
butting heads all time very great love
that story and in story arcs that they
end up together and you assume they die
in the cold drinking whisky how I'd like
to go out
I had seven pages of full notes and then
eight was just one one giant note and it
was what Wilford Brimley is Blair nobody
remember see Wilford Brimley and
anything other than the diabetes
commercial hi
I will for Brimley and I have type 2
diabetes
and I get my testing supplies from
Liberty Mutual and I'm on a horse all
right let's look at some of these
predictions very excited the state of
the dogs will upset you yes how did you
know that I would be so upset about the
dog you'll want more Rexford cards or
movies and we'll eventually watch
Halloween okay yeah see I lift them up
at the beginning of this reaction video
I haven't seen Halloween but I really
want to see some of his other things you
were surprised it was better than you
expected like all 500 others it never
changes just kidding by the way I love
your videos thank you um what I guess
better than I expected I was expecting
this one to be good though so in a way
that I normally like wasn't expecting
that this was like hell yeah lived up to
expectations Kurt Russell was going to
be one of your favorite characters he
grew on me he wasn't initially though
but I have a weird thing against Kurt
Russell if it don't know why that's my
bad my problem Wilford Brimley gets very
cranky about his insulin shots as he
should that was better than any part of
the movie with the credits just finding
out that Wilford Brimley the type 2
diabetes man that I've known and loved
and whenever I say I'm diabetes people
are like oh like Wilford Brimley like
this totally different things okay
yes was in the movie the spider had will
give you nightmares
I can this to bed yet but now it will
four out of ten not enough things I
didn't think that watching it but but
now that you say it I would have been
joined if there were just like at one
point like six things coming at them
that would have been awesome because
then that would just been a lot of
flame-throwing which I obviously love
just pages of you writing holy shit even
so basically that's no way to treat a
chess computer that is what I thought my
brother was like that's the ultimate
ragequit for the eighties I was like I
like a really expensive way to rage quit
though you'll also probably want Jim to
make you something speak things seemed
at some point that would be cool though
personally I don't think I will just
because there was no female in this
movie there was no woman in this film
and that's fine that's how the story was
written I'm not saying that they were
doing it it's like a sexist thing I'm
just saying I there's no one that I'm
like hell yeah I want to be her or
cosplay her like be that you know
remember the fly that'll be your
reaction that's perfect I'm ending it
there I know you viewers have been
through a lot but I'd rather not spend
the rest of spring on this
[Music]
[Applause]